Mind Your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar
4 ^ x + 6 ^ x = 9 ^ x
Solve for all real values of x that satisfy this equation
I thank Ritwik in India for suggesting this problem
It came from an IIT jee sample paper, but I've also seen it shared on the internet with the catch phrase
"You should be able to solve this"
Pause the video if you'd like to give this problem a try. And when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
We'll get started by dividing each term by 4 to the power of x
the first term simplifies to be 1
the next term becomes 6 over 4 all raised to the power of x and
The third term becomes 9 over 4 raised to the power of x
6 over 4 is equal to 3 over 2 and we'll substitute that in
9 over 4 is equal to 3 over 2 the quantity squared and we'll substitute that in
We now simplify 3 over 2 squared all raised to the power of x
This becomes 3 over 2 all raised to the power of 2x
now make the substitution that 3 over 2 raised to the power of x is equal to u
If we square both sides of the equation. We get 3 over 2 all raised to the power of 2x is equal to u squared
We thus have a quadratic equation 1 plus u is equal to u squared
We'll move the terms to the right hand side. So we get 0 is equal to u squared minus u minus 1
Since u is equal to 3 over 2 all raised to the power of x
We need u to be greater than 0 because three-halves raised to the power of x will be a positive term
We then use the quadratic formula and simplify
We get that u is equal to the golden ratio 1 plus the square root of 5 all over 2
But we're not done yet. We want to solve for x
since three-halves raised to the power of x is equal to u
We want to solve for x by taking the natural log of both sides
We can then bring the exponent down and then solve for x by dividing line the natural log of three-halves
We substitute in for u and we get our exact answer
x is equal to the natural log of the golden ratio
divided by the natural log of three-halves and this simplifies to be approximately 1.187
At first the problem was quite intimidating, but with some clever substitutions, we found the golden answer
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube
As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support.